during these market downturns we
obviously see stocks down uh crypto real
estate bond i mean just everything is
going down and uh you know it uh goes
back to this idea it's all one trade the
fed's in control and they're gonna drive
this stuff down until they feel like uh
people have capitulated uh what are
institutional investors thinking about
right now when they're watching this
play out obviously they have some direct
investing they have uh probably much
more uh kind of investing through
general partners and through fund
managers but like what's going through
the heads of these institutional
investors right now
so it's it's a
it's a great question that
you have to answer in pieces there are
really great institutional investors i
was just with you know the fairfax folks
that you and i know well uh last
thursday up in dc so think about this in
the midst of all of this turmoil markets
crashing you said every asset going down
they called together all of their
private investors venture capital growth
equity buyouts
energy
uh
and put us all in a room together for a
day on thursday and just had a massive
idea session genius right take people
you're paying lots of money to do smart
things for you and let's see if there's
some opportunities that come out of all
this turmoil and they got some really
good ideas so the really smart ones like
catherine and andy are going to do that
kind of stuff
the the
the less smart ones
are going to do what human beings do
human beings do two things really really
well we buy what we wish we would have
bought and we sell we're about to need
you and i debated this this morning
actually
um so
the problem with
uh
most investors
and institutions a little bit less but
they're just as guilty as the
individuals the individuals are the
worst about this right they constantly
buy the top and then they sell the
bottom but the institutions also chase
hot dots
and so there are some institutions that
are looking around saying well there are
no hot dots so what do i do
so
they are
probably selling some things like all
the the nasty stuff about the hedge
funds and the tiger cubs and all that
stuff there are people they're going to
try to redeem from those things that's
probably a mistake
um and one of the things about investing
that that i tried to live and i was
actually decent at it but not not
perfect
but
what you should do
you should never buy something that has
had a hot three-year period
you should sell that because it's going
to mean revert what you should do is
find somebody
who has a great 10 year track record
who's just had a terrible
one two three year run like and the
worst the better
and give that person money so there are
some that are out there doing that and
those are the the real geniuses
i think the last thing is
i i think some of this being talked
about at the institutional level a lot
right now
is the same thing as being talked about
at the individual level which is well
wait a second this is different what
about all these assets that were
supposed to be uncorrelated why are they
all going down at the same time i
thought bonds were supposed to not go
down if stocks went down they're
supposed to be a safe haven i thought
gold was supposed to be a safe haven i
thought you know crypto is supposed to
be a safe haven i thought international
stocks weren't supposed to be correlated
with u.s stocks well here's the problem
the everything bubble which was the
result of the excessive central bank
liquidity around the world caused all
assets to move
to stupidville right you mentioned the
market cap to gdp right worse than 2000
price to sales ratio worse than 2000 so
equities got to stupidville bonds listen
to greg foss on twitter right rail about
this got to stupidville
and everything commodities and all of it
went up and so what happened is when
they cut off the liquidity
the first thing started to correct
well the problem this time was people
didn't just buy with cash they bought
with margin
everybody bought with margin even some
of the institutions bought with margin
because the goldman sachses and others
for japan were given them margin
and so we had the highest margin ever in
history well in it when you get a margin
call
right your stock falls 20 you get a
margin call you're supposed to put in
more money
you don't get to sell what you want to
sell you sell what you have to sell you
sell what's most liquid so that's what
causes everything to fall you saw it in
march of 2020 and you've seen it in the
last two three weeks here
and when that starts to happen people
start questioning the whole theory of
diversification now marco it's won the
nobel prize and it i have a t-shirt says
markowitz was right and it does work but
in the short run it gets temporarily
suspended and i think that does prompt
some people to make bad decisions so you
got to avoid that urge
to make those bad decisions
and you know i've said this to many
others many other times but investing i
think literally is the only business i
know
when things go on sale people run out of
the store
and the cheaper the price the further
they run
think about any other bits you put
wedding dresses on sale
they all run in the store they don't run
out of the store they run in the store
when you think about uh prices going up
of assets there's lots of talk about
hold them they're compounding you know
the charlie munger warren buffett never
interrupt uh compounding unnecessarily
then there's another school of thought
of rebalancing and kind of hitting your
uh allocation target percentages etc
what do the institutions do on the way
down are they rebalancing are they uh uh
trying to
take let's say a pension fund as an
example like do they try to maybe not
pay out as fast or what are like the
tactical things that they do on the way
down that maybe people aren't aware of
uh where they're trying to essentially
stop the bleeding maybe or at least
address the problem
now again two really important points so
one is is the rebalancing the good ones
right the swenson acolytes etc you know
rest in peace david um they do rebalance
and and that was something that
i was always really proud of the way we
did that at carolina and at notre dame
is is we're very active rebounds because
when you're in the endowment business or
the pension business you're not in the
get-rich business
concentration makes you rich
diversification keeps you rich and
rebalancing keeps you richer
because you're constantly buying cheap
and selling deer
um all great fortunes in the world came
from concentration
how do you create a small fortune start
with a large fortune and stay
concentrated so there will always be
cycles and if you can hold forever right
in a tax-deferred structure like
berkshire you should do that but you
should lever up that's what they do but
most people
uh should just constantly rebalance with
a good plan they should have some
get-rich money i would say you should
have three buckets liquidity bucket to
fund your lifestyle a get-rich-bucket to
do all the fun stuff the friends condo
deal the brother-in-law's venture you're
gonna lose at all anyway so just make it
small and then stay rich bucket
diversify that and these institutions
are looking at that storage bucket and
saying okay my equities just fell a lot
my tech equities fell more let's go buy
some stuff that's on sale maybe buy some
chinese equities maybe buy some of these
these cloud companies although i think
the cloud companies are still too
expensive
um
then on the flip side they're looking at
their private port and here's the one
problem
the very best of the very best
the yales the notre dames the you know
unc's etc the very best of the very best
in performance they have this lag
problem
the public markets adjust immediately
and then you have a denominator problem
because your private markets don't
adjust and so you have a denominator
problem and that your total fund value
went down so your weighting in private
went up but you can't really sell unless
you sell in the secondary market and
you're going to take a massive haircut
because there's very little liquidity so
doing that doesn't make any sense so you
have to actually talk to your el to your
gps and say well how far are valuations
actually going to fall because they're
going to fall
but they'll be sticky down instead of
immediate because in private it's the
escalator up
i mean in public is the escalator up in
the elevator down
right in the private world it's the
escalator up and the escalator down it
just takes longer to come down